The Revolutionary Armed Forces of
Colombia, the FARC, is the guerrilla organization
that the administration of Juan Manuel Santos has
negotiated a peace agreement with.
The FARC dates back 52 years, founded to
wage an insurrection against the
democratic institutions of Colombia,
attacking the oligarchic political
system and economic system through the use of force.
In the mid-1990s,
the FARC evolved into the
biggest cocaine smuggling organization in the world,
and they used this to generate revenue.
The FARC is not a
popular organization by any means today.
They probably command less than
three or four percent of the vote.
The question is, with the opportunity to
establish a presence on the ground
unassailed by the government,
will they build up their base of popular support?
Undermine confidence in the democratic
institutions in the elected government
of Colombia,  which is south America's
oldest democracy.